Joseph I I've always approached others
to partner with me in business what do I
miss that these people do not approach
me so I guess he's always out pitching
people who know what is coming to him
how does he fix that it's great question
Joseph in terms of me personally with my
results I know I get a lot more no sense
No thank yous or the dreaded no response
then I will a conversation so so don't
be discouraged and definitely keep going
but coming back to it it's really want
to be you want to be able to be
discoverable and you want to be
providing content something of value to
to that customer base and to that those
partnerships that you're trying to
establish I think that's so important so
just just keeping great content and on
your site within your newsletters it's
going to be really important there um
video is definitely one thing where that
i would i would encourage you to to take
full advantage of as well too but yeah i
would go all in on what you're good at
for me I actually I'm a pretty shy
person may not come across and these
videos and everything but I'm very
introverted and so for me doing sales
calls and cold calling people and
networking I hate it I suck at it I
don't want to get better at it no
interest it's tough o Allah I would I'll
bring on John to help me if I need maybe
ROM so you know if my business dependent
on that for me to be successful I would
fail luckily there's a lot of different
ways to be successful and in my approach
is to try to kick up as much noise and
provide as much value as possible in my
industry so people come to me I do that
through my youtube channel right will do
two and a half million views this month
on the channel instead of going to
conferences and being a member I'm
speaking at conferences and then
afterwards people come to me and ask me
questions that want to do kind of
partnerships so I just try to kick up as
much noise as I can provide as much
value as I can doing what I'm really
good at and that attracts people to be a
part of what I'm doing um I think a big
part of that is being authentic and
genuine I tell my story a lot I share
personal examples I love entrepreneur
you know I hope that comes through and
everything that I'm doing and that
attracts kind of the right kind of
people to my business instead of me
having to go out and head hunt but that
works for me it doesn't work for
everybody yeah justjust do do it once
and do it really good and just do a case
study or refer back to that to that
partnership and be able to send that out
to the next partnership that you're out
there seeking to show that partner that
you've done it before and this was the
results that's something that we a day
wherever here do as well with with
partnerships or if that's just different
customers as well